- I guess what I think veganism is...
- I went to vegans for Dummies.
- I don't know much about veganism,
but what I do know...
- (laughs) It sucks!
(intense music)
- Starting tomorrow, the
four of us will be vegans
for the next thirty days.
- I don't feel good about
being on a vegan diet.
- Hell no. (laughs)
- What am I going to do with tofu?
- I would probably suckle
directly from a cow's teat.
- My diet now
is like whatever.
- I don't know what I'm
going to do without cheese.
- Yeah, I have some concerns.
One, my sanity.
- I just hate the thought of like
restricting what I eat.
- We're doing this for a month
because we actually do want to really
have the time to take this seriously
and learn about what
it means to be a vegan.
- I wanna try a vegan diet maybe because
that's the way of the future.
- I feel like this'll be a good cleanse
for my body.
- To say, at the end of this,
that I will go vegan, very slim chances.
However, maybe I come out of this
and get in the habit of cooking more
and just doing better things
to my body in general.
- It's day one, and Ryan already cheated.
- [Ryan] Alright, so she just recorded me
saying I'm eating this...
- I'm eating salad all day.
We are going to meet with the nutritionist
and get some advice because
none of us know how to be good vegans.
- I work out a lot, and I'm
really concerned about protein.
- You actually don't have
to worry too much about it
because a lot of the grains
in the plant-based foods
that you're eating, that
replace the protein,
so the grains, the legumes, the beans...
Those foods have a lot of protein in them.
- [Jared] Is there anything
vegan that's delicious?
- Yeah, there's tons of stuff that's vegan
that's delicious.
- [Jared] Like what?
- Like avocados are delicious,
I like most fruits and vegetables, so...
- Great. Thank you so much!
- You're welcome!
- This has been very, very illuminating.
- I am no longer happy when I'm hungry.
And that's kind of sad.
- It's really sad.
- [Jared] Yeah, it's a little sad.
- [Jen] Three hot dogs at work,
- [Jared] Three hot
dogs, but we're getting
vegan hot dogs...
- Vegan hot dogs.
- Getting a chili dog, must be nice.
But I'm not afforded that luxury
because BuzzFeed is
hell-bent on punishing me
for no reason.
- We're about two weeks into being vegan
and I feel pretty much the same.
I think I'm just a tired
person to begin with,
so any other additional tiredness
just kinds of blends in.
- It's definitely been
like a roller coaster,
both mentally and physically.
Over the past couple of days,
I've been like pushing
myself to go out to different
vegan restaurants and try
a bunch of awesome vegan cuisine.
- I've actually started
paying a lot more attention
to what I eat,
and I've been eating a
lot more fresh veggies,
lot more varied foods.
- I feel really tired all the time.
I'm constantly tired and I
think it's because my body
is lacking protein.
- Cheated again!
- It wasn't my fault!
This guy! Not me!
- So we realized on day one,
as (inaudiable) holds a cream
cheese bagel in his hand,
that people were just
going to cheat willy-nilly
if we didn't have some
kind of rule going on.
So now, we have a rule where if you cheat,
you get a punishment.
- Long story short, Justin Tan
had a turkey vegan sandwich,
or what he thought was
a turkey vegan sandwich,
gave it to me, and was like
"wow, you've got to taste
this vegan sandwich, it's pretty good."
- I thought it was vegan!
- [Ryan] He told me
this sandwich was vegan
from the (bleep) green vegan truck!
- As part of Ryan's punishment,
we got him a veggie burger and then
Justin will be eating his favorite meal,
which happens to be...
- A four-by-four from In-N-Out.
- Yo! What's up?
- [Ryan] Are you freaking kidding me?
What the?
Wait, are you serious?
- [Justin] Come on and have a seat, man.
You have a nice, tasty veggie
burger waiting for you.
- You piece of (bleep)!
- Here, I'm going to
take my first bite here.
Mmm.
- (Bleep) you.
- There's an ice cream truck today.
And we can have none of it.
- Yeah, man! Ice cream!
- Brett Wood. Brett Wood!
- I'm in the last week of veganism.
And I feel...
ready for a burger.
- In the beginning, I was
using a lot of fake meat
to replace real meat,
and it was actually making
me feel a lot worse.
After that, I decided to start
eating more natural food.
So, more fruits, more veggies,
and I started to feel a lot better.
- I do think it's possible
to be a meat eater
and to use dairy without contributing to
sort of cruel practices,
like, there are farms that
treat their animals ethically.
- In the last week of
this, we are going to
our coworker Caroline's house
where she's going to cook us a vegan meal
that's actually good.
She's a vegan expert,
so I'll have a chance
to eat something that's
not beans and rice.
(light music)
- I'm vegan.
- I'm vegetarian.
- But an excellent vegan chef.
A couple of weeks ago, I was talking to
Daysha and Ryan about
what they were eating,
and it was making me very sad,
so I wanted to show them
what actual vegan food
can be like.
- [Roni] We're going to do yellow curry,
we're going to do some lard,
and then a sweet sticky rice,
coconut, and mango.
- [Daysha] We're like
where the kids helping out
at Thanksgiving dinner.
- [Roni] Whenever somebody's milling about
major life choices like
the food you're gonna eat,
the thing that you really
define your culture by,
that can be really off-putting
to a lot of people.
But I think if you show it like this,
that you can make delicious food
that's not a deprivation,
I think that's much more
encouraging to people
to lead a healthier life.
Maybe the last little
bit is very necessary,
in our changing environment.
- I'm no longer vegan.
It's been one week since
our experiment ended.
I feel pretty good.
- It definitely had its highs and lows.
But overall, I would say
being a vegan wasn't terrible.
- Going into this, I didn't really know
what being vegan was about,
as far as why people do it.
And now I understand why.
It's (bleep)ed up, all
the stuff that we do
to get the meat that we do.
- Reintroducing meat
and dairy into my diet
wasn't the mind-blowing
thing that I thought
it was going to be.
It was just like "oh,
yeah, it's just food."
- You know, maybe I'll find some
more ethically raised meat.
Chipotle serves ethically raised meat.
- Your diet is often tied
very closely to your identity
and your culture, and I
think huge diet changes
can be really difficult to adopt.
Not just on a superficial taste level,
but also on an emotional
and a cultural level.
I sort of have a greater appreciation
for what goes into my food
and what goes into my body.
- I'm just very appreciative of the fact
that being vegan has helped me feel good
when eating.
I think that my whole life,
I've always struggled with food
and making sure I'm eating right,
and trying to be a certain size.
You just learn how to eat right,
that feeling of feeling
good feels so much better
than trying to be a certain size.